welcome back to peers walking on a sense
to the Miss England contest has revealed
it could restore its bikini competition
after 20 years of self-censorship the
pageant used to feature a swimming
around the budding Beauty to Showcase
their physical fitness but it was banned
in 2002 amid claims of sexism well
earlier this year Miss Northern Ireland
ditched its bikini around other concerns
it was distracting from the true meaning
of the contest which suggests to me they
didn't understand the true meaning of
the contest but Angie Beasley the
director of his England says she's
refusing to bow down to the woke Brigade
as she mulls the big decision adding
it's great to be empowering women to
feel confident in their own skin so this
is Firebrand feminism or just Stone Age
sexism and what frankly is so offensive
about bikinis well I'm joined by the
former Miss USA Sarah Rose Summers uh
Nirvana Noel the former Miss Croatia and
a feminist campaign and current Miss
North London I've given her that title
Julian bentle all right Julie let me
start with you miss North London
um which I'm sure you would have won if
you'd ever entered
um what's your problem with this I I
never understood what they took it away
I thought the whole point of beauty
pageants was the name on the tin
suggests it was about physical Beauty
and we got to celebrate the beautiful
female form who cares
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
celebrating Beauty there's nothing wrong
with women's own definition of beauty
the problem is pitting women against
each other competitively and Men
deciding
who is conventionally attractive
in the sense of the very sexist
stereotypes and women that girls under
the cost of and women used to watch them
of course but there's no why are you
singling at me there's little Point
putting
that's because there's little Point
using women as a smoke screen to suggest
that because of course I agree that
women have the right to do what they
wish with their own bodies there's no
point suggesting that this is about
women and women's empowerment and agency
when this comes from men this comes from
the directive but women's worth should
be measured with conventional Beauty
like I say I have no issue with women
let me challenge you on this what is
wrong with celebrating conventional
Beauty I used to love watching Miss
World and those things absolutely
look the competitiveness
of these Beauty competitions is sexism
on steroid their competitions to see
users
it's the whole point of it women lose
and women win and this is exactly how
women are socialized to feel worthless
compared
you don't believe this beauty standard
that is set by Men Without sexism we
wouldn't have missed last time I checked
and obviously if you think about what
happens in these competitions there are
so many women last time I checked
millions of women watched these
competitions on TV too they love them
it's irrelevant as it is what I'm
talking about is the because it's about
the message that it sends to girls to
women in society that this is something
that oh you have to wear loads of
clothes otherwise otherwise and not to
men so you can only be in a beauty
pageant if you wear head to toe clothing
that covers all your flesh it sounds
like something out of North Korea Saudi
Arabia themselves
no no beauty pageants in and of
themselves
are a symbol of sexism I'm not
suggesting Banning them I'm not
suggesting locking up those that
organize them or profit from them such
as Donald Trump of course that
well-known pro-feminist man who owned
Miss Universe the stories about the
sexual harassment sexual assault and
terrible treatment of women in these
pageants have been circulating for
decades
all right all of the reports from women
about what happens to them during these
patterns let me go to someone who won uh
Miss USA and Miss Universe Sarah Rose
Summers Sarah you've been laughing away
listening to this because apparently
you're you're a tormented victim and
this is demeaning and sexist and male
things like well you basically implied
that it's only men like me who are you
know being sexist pigs and watching it
well okay you implied it was a male
issue that because men are objectifying
women like Sarah so Sarah did you feel
did you feel objectified and a victim
I did not I think it's just so important
in this feminist female empowerment
movement that we support each other's
dreams and goals and aspirations and no
one ever forced me to compete in Miss
Nebraska USA Miss USA Miss Universe that
was something I chose to do and I
started competing in pageants without a
swimsuit competition
um back when I was just 10 years old I
was super shy it brought me public
speaking skills interview skills taught
me confidence how to hold myself on a
stage and in a swimsuit and long term I
believe the swimsuit competition is a
positive for Miss contestants
specifically because it really did teach
me a healthy lifestyle it taught me to
long-term sustain you know I never
neglected My Sweet Tooth I love my
sweets but I found ways I enjoyed moving
my body and that's not something that
came natural to me either I think that's
so important when people hear that I'm
Pro swimsuit competition they instantly
think oh well you know look at you you
clearly you don't have to work for it by
any means well that is completely false
genetics have definitely been against me
I've watched my mom yo yo diet and diet
her whole life and so I knew firsthand
that I wanted to be proactive and stay
fit so I enjoy workout classes and
things of that nature so for myself and
most everyone it's a very close-knit
group of women you know we're all very
like-minded we have big lofty goals in
our very philanthropic focused so some
of my best friends I've met through
pageantry and I would say that all of us
would unanimously agree that the
competitions that are in Miss USA Miss
Universe have only strengthened our
confidence okay
I like that and I I think that's exactly
what my feedback has been I've actually
judged one of these things Miss UK I
think it was
um eventually yeah I did interesting I
thoroughly enjoyed it I thought it was a
wonderful my judges panel
yeah I thought it was a wonderful judges
panel was fully made of women as well
right I mean I just thought it was a
celebration of of feminist empowerment
frankly uh Ivana you are not exactly shy
uh we see a lot of you on your Instagram
um and you're wearing I think your
swimsuit as we speak uh what do you make
of this I mean do you think there's any
any Merit to the argument that perhaps
it is a bit demeaning for women to in a
beauty pageant have to wear swimsuits
and their peers I cannot even think I
I'm not I cannot believe in 2023 we'll
discussed about this uh I am a bikini
owner of uh SSC and first of all bikini
is a part of life even every Grandma
Grand grandpa has a bikini guys wearing
bikini bye guys are not sexual as I to
wearing men's shorts it's totally
different
um men can be a hormonal crazy about
woman very completely Legends and
covered it doesn't need to be bikini for
sexualism you know he can say oh this
girl is hot even full dress it's how we
behave and how we allow guys to behave
with us if I say hey I don't care about
your hormones I'm very bikini and I want
to be respected I'm respected and girl
who is coming to our competition for
Miss World she need to be confident and
she don't care about guy who is thinking
with hormones I I don't think this girl
should even be in the competition
because if she is shy and she's afraid
to be sexualized then this poor girl
should be in a living room and watch on
TV screen I completely agree let me
bring Julie back Julie isn't this a
point you don't have to enter these
things they are a competition I used to
judge Britain's Got Talent and America's
Got Talent we'd have all sorts of people
on uh with all sorts of talents now no
one's forcing them to be there there's
no gun to these young ladies heads
they're on it because they want to show
off their beauty and last time I checked
we are allowed to celebrate the
beautiful female form as indeed we are
to celebrate the beautiful male form you
know when you're looking at it
I mean I had had your producer told me
that I would be debating with two women
about this I would have chosen not to
come on the program because I will not
argue with women about the choices they
make my argument is against the men that
set these conventional beauty standards
that impose this these standards on
girls and women growing up most of whom
feel that they are being judged and that
they are being demeaned eventually just
have the complete opposite more or less
than their own honestly
competitiveness Between Women is the
worst thing possible when actually we
need to stick together so I wouldn't
have chosen to come on the program had I
known I was debating with these two
women because my argument isn't with
them it's with the men that uphold these
standards right but what you're
conveniently ignoring is we've had two
women who've Taken part in these
pageants who both say that there's no
problem the women and all enjoy being on
it they'd like a bit of friendly
competition they're all supportive of
each other they don't feel remotely
bothered about men objectifying them
because as many women watch it as men I
really don't see what the problem is I
love thousands and thousands of
testimonies from women all over the
world since the 1960s that have been in
beauty pageants that talk about hideous
misogynistic treatment by men where they
talk about rape and sexual assault
sexual harassment and being thrown away
and discarded once they get to the age
of 27 which is the age limit and being
told that they're over the hill so there
are stories that we haven't heard
tonight and I would tell your your
viewers maybe go and do a little bit of
Google research and have a look at this
okay so let me ask you this then what
how do you feel then about public
beaches High streets where women March
around in bikinis especially my issue
isn't with with my issue isn't with
nakedness on nudity my issue is with the
value placed upon
women competing with each other
for who has the perfect in the eyes of
sexist men that judge women
honestly
with nakedness Julian I think it's such
a lame thing to say that it's just
sexist men that watch these things they
don't I know loads of women well it's
true love watching cutie pageants and
admiring the beauty as they do by the
way when they buy women's magazines and
see beautiful women on the cover I don't
want to hold women up
Julie I made no apology for admiring the
beautiful female form including yourself
and my two eyes and I wouldn't ask you
two peers I know I'm just offering my my
appreciation of Miss North London
is that okay
and Julie I think it's important to note
like I had said earlier that my panel of
Judges was solely women that were
successful in their industry so I wasn't
shredding my stuff up there answering on
stage questions to men as you keep
mentioning thankfully
um
but I would say honestly Sarah I would
say just because men like watching
beauty pageants doesn't make us all a
bunch of sexist pigs you can appreciate
a beautiful woman of course not in the
most
non-sexisting I admire Beauty I'd like
it in all guises I like a beautiful
Arsenal football player as much as I
admire a beautiful woman
thank you Julie we've reached a point of
agreement I think or at least
acknowledgment I'm allowed to like
beautiful things lovely to speak to all
three of you thank you very much indeed